-I'm gonna ask you both
for some silly words.
Nouns, verbs, adjectives,
et cetera.
And as we do that, they'll
be written onto cue cards,
and then we're gonna act out
a dramatic Mad Libs scene.
Ready for this?
-Yeah. Really dramatic.
-All right, yeah.
Very dramatic.
All right, Kenan,
give me a silly word.
-Silly word. "Butt."
[ Laughter ]
-Joe, food at a barbecue?
-Heinz Ketchup.
-Thanks. Adjective?
-Funky.
-Cartoon character?
-Hong Kong Phooey.
-Wow! Nice!
-Deep cut.
-Wow!
Hong Kong Phooey, man.
[ Laughter ]
Kenan, give me a state.
-Georgia.
-Uh, a plural occupation.
-Plural occupation?
-Yes.
-Farmhands.
[ Laughter ]
-What?!
-First thing
that came to mind.
-Oh, my gosh. Country.
-United States of America.
-There you go, buddy. USA.
A plural item of clothing.
-Plural item of clothing.
Um, oh, I just came from Europe,
and this is on
your laundry list,
for men and women -- panties.
-Interesting.
-Panties.
If you send underwear,
like, your boxer shorts,
to get washed at a hotel,
you have to check
the "panties" box.
-Are you serious?
-Swear, yeah.
-Just be open
to new experiences.
-Listen.
Jimmy, just go with it.
-I'm going with it.
Kenan, give me a number.
-1,100,060.
[ Laughter ]
-Not making this easy on him.
-Yeah. Wow.
All right. Give me a month.
-A month. December.
-Is that your birthday?
-It is.
-A type of salad.
-Greek.
-Joe, a greeting
that you give your puppy
after being gone the entire day.
-"Oooh, you little..."
-Oooh, you...
-O-O-O...
-Oooh, you little...
"Oooh, you little..."
Kenan, a verb ending in I-N-G.
-Fastening.
Doing a lot of fastening
of the shoes lately.
-I'm tying --
-Fastening.
-I'm teaching my daughter
how to tie her shoes.
Lot of fastening.
-Your daughter's 36, right?
-Yeah.
She's doing really well.
We're proud of her.
-Joe, celebrity name.
-Kim Kardashian.
-There you go.
-I don't know why --
-That's great.
-Celebrity.
-Kim Kardashian.
Kenan, what you shout
when you find out
you've been accepted
to the college of your dreams.
-"How much?!"
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's it. A plural noun.
-Plural noun.
-Yep.
-Um, um -- Bananas.
Ba-non-as. Ba-non-as.
-Ba-non-as.
Past-tense verb.
-What? Past-tense verb?
Sorry.
Ran?
-Yep.
-Was that a past-tense verb?
-Yeah.
Another plural
article of clothing.
-Gosh. Clip-on ties.
[ Laughter ]
-Gotta have 'em.
-Clip-on ties.
-Body part.
-Foot.
-A noun.
Uh, uh, Chicago.
-Yeah. Place.
-Person, place, or thing.
-Yeah.
-That's a thing. Yeah.
-First noun -- Chicago.
That's right.
Kenan, food you'd order
at a sushi restaurant.
-Shrimp tempura roll.
-Yeah, okay.
Shrimp tempura roll.
-And delicious.
-A childhood punishment.
-Childhood punishment.
The bar of soap in the mouth.
-All right.
Now we're gonna do --
This is the speed round here.
Real quick right here.
Kenan, exclamation.
-Hooray!
-Another verb ending in I-N-G.
-Um, uh, uh, beating.
-Beating.
-Wow.
-I don't --
Oh, my God, I can't even --
It started with farmhands.
That's when
it went off the rails.
Farmhands.
-Farmhands.
-That's all right. I'm good.
Mall restaurant.
-Uh, whew.
We'll go with Taco Bell.
-Taco Bell. There you go.
Mall clothing store.
-Mall clothing store.
Um, um, Spencer's?
Spencer's Gifts.
They have T-shirts.
-I guess they have --
They have clothing there?
-Yeah, T-shirts --
-And, like, young
adolescent pornography.
-Yes, they do.
Spencer's Gifts. There you go.
We've filled out
the words for our scene.
Let's go perform the scene.
Let's do this right now.
Are you guys ready?
-Let's do it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Organ playing cheerful music ]
♪♪
-All right.
Welcome back, baseball fans.
I'm Steve Butt.
Alongside me is my co-announcer,
Kyle Heinz Ketchup.
-Thank you very much.
No relation. No relation.
We're live on this
beautiful, funky night
from the historic
Hong Kong Phooey Stadium.
We're gonna change that.
-We're in the ninth inning
of a very close matchup
between the Georgia Farmhands
versus the United States
of America Panties.
-That's --
-The score is tied
1,100,060 to 1,100,060.
-Wow. This is very exciting.
Joining us now
is our special guest.
Retired all-star pitcher.
None other than the one and only
December Greek.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oooh, you little...!
Great to be here tonight.
I've never seen a stadium
with so many fans
fastening so loudly.
-It's been quite a game.
Lots of great moments so far.
Including when Kim Kardashian
streaked across the field.
-How much?!
I can't believe that!
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-All right.
-Wow. Wow.
-Now, December Greek,
you hold the record
for most bananas ran --
-I think you mean ba-non-as.
-Ba-non-as.
-That's right.
-Did you have
any pregame superstitions?
-Actually, yes, I did.
Before every game, I would
go into the locker room,
put on fresh clip-on ties,
and rub my foot
with my lucky Chicago.
-Wow! Wow!
-That's a very popular noun --
Chicago.
A very popular noun.
-Back to the game --
-That's what I think of first.
The word Chicago,
that's a great noun.
-Back to the game.
Stepping up to the plate
is Mike Shrimp Tempura Roll.
-Uh-huh.
-Oh, here we go.
Bases loaded, full count.
If Mike Shrimp Tempura Roll
doesn't get a hit,
his manager is gonna get
a bar of soap in the mouth.
-All right.
-There it is.
-Here's the pitch.
He swings! There it goes!
Hooray! It is gone!
-Yeah.
He's beating around the bases.
I've never seen this before.
-What a game!
All right, guys, it's time
to sing our favorite song.
-♪ Take me out
to the Taco Bell ♪
♪ Take me out
to the Spencer's ♪
♪ For it's one, two,
three strikes, you're out ♪
♪ At the old Taco Bell ♪
-And scene!
My thanks to Kenan Thompson,
Joe Manganiello!